yes Chloe gave birth to a baby girl in
Cleveland on Thursday around 4 a.m.
Eastern the baby doesn't have a name yet
but a source close to the Kardashian
says that baby and mom are healthy but
that's just the tip of the iceberg
because I know you guys are wondering
was Tristan there okay well there's been
a lot of scandal about Tristan Thompson
allegedly cheating on Chloe lately and
so with this birth we're like what's
gonna happen Tristan was there it's
unclear however whether or not he was
actually in the delivery room according
to our source though Chloe was
surrounded by family and friends her
sisters Kim and Kourtney also her best
friend Malika and of course mom Kris
Jenner and horse Kris has mr. bird there
for every single birthday no way she was
gonna miss and because of all this drama
the source has also been telling us that
the family has been trying to keep it
very zen in the delivery room we should
and just supporting Chloe and the source
also says that kris has barely left
Khloe's side with all of this and right
now she knows Chloe needs to just focus
on the baby
here's the thing though it's not all
drama because I mean there's drama
there's never a dull moment but another
source tells et that they're not letting
the drama really damper the exciting
news of this baby the source tells us
that it wasn't exactly how we expected
it to happen regarding all the Tristan
drama but they also say for now all
anyone cares about and is talking about
is the baby everyone is thrilled and
despite everything else that's going on
this is an incredibly happy day the
drama isn't going to overshadow that
thank goodness because can you imagine I
mean the it's already such a high stress
situation giving birth and I especially
being a Kardashian think about it like
you know we're also told that she
prepared for this with a lot of police
activity and barricades and a lot of
people had a sign like non-disclosure
agreement so it's very stressful to have
to give birth as a Kardashian but then
in the middle of all this cheating drama
which I don't think anyone expected
obviously this one source says it wasn't
exactly how they plan to welcome the
baby child but it happened it happened
our source says that Tristan has been
apologetic and begging for forgiveness
since the scandal your girl was pregnant
yeah listen I'm just a normal pregnant
I'm halfway through my coffee and I
cannot imagine going through this it's
absolutely insane you're already
stressed out you're already scared
excited like feeling everything that you
could possibly be feeling and childbirth
is like not a walk you know security
having to deal with not necessarily
feeling that support from your partner
as well at that moment like Chloe
good for you which makes sense why like
honestly yeah and of course it makes
sense why our source is saying that
she's just gonna focus on the baby and
you know our source also says that Chloe
is crushed I mean I think any of us
would be if we were in that situation
but she wants to believe that nothing is
wrong and isn't willing to give up right
away you know our source says that
Tristan is the man that Chloe loves and
so much more exactly she wants to spend
her life with it and I thought this time
with the baby whether they decide to
stay together or not right how do you
think this will play out
it will be interesting I mean what Chloe
has been wanting a baby for so long that
I'm so happy for her
and I think that she really will
continue to focus on that I just think
for a while you know maybe they'll try
to work things out and we've heard that
Chloe's not gonna make any rash
decisions which I do not blame her going
through childbirth and and just adapting
to being a mother for the first time
like it's not really the time that you
want to cut off I think with your
partner but that said I think she's
gonna have a lot of decisions to make
down the line I mean obviously and like
we've learned that there's definitely
some conflicting emotions for Chloe
there as you guys mentioned she's always
family
she thought Tristan is the one I still
think she thinks he's the one so we'll
see how it plays out but the good news
is the baby is healthy and so is mama
and the source tells us that the baby's
beautiful you know where Tristan's gonna
be in the next week or so yeah so
Tristan is actually gonna stick around
for about a week because he has games
with the Cleveland Cavaliers
interesting though he played last night
against the Knicks and he apparently our
source tells us was being booed and
there were also what I've seen on
Twitter there were fans that were
holding up sign saying I heart Chloe so
will be interesting to see if he gets
that same reaction as he plays these
games I know
battle lines have been drawn on the
thing to note to it's like you know
they're trying to work out you know all
of this stuff that's going on but also
he's on the road right as the babies
they're like there's just so much going
on in their world or fashion when you're
trying to build up trust too with
somebody and they're out on the road
like that's got to be really hard I mean
no doubt she has the full support of her
sisters and the rest of the family I
mean I reported to you guys yesterday
that the family is united in this and
they're gonna help Chloe get through it
they don't want this to be a distraction
they want her to just focus on the baby
but they're definitely showing a united
front and they've all been silent for
now which has been their their thing
lately you know and there's a scandal
that breaks or a big news story that has
to do with the family they take a beat
now so you know props to them but we
also say side note just congratulations
she's my mom for so long and this is
such an exciting like happy moment for
her to have her daughter so Chloe were
so excited for you that's awesome
we're Team Coco we've always been in
fact you guys are too some comments are
coming in from out actually for Facebook
she's so happy for Chloe
but Ashley says she needs to drop
Tristan and concentrate on herself and
the baby okay Ashley a lot of support
coming through for Chloe from you guys
Simone from YouTube says happy the baby
came safely that baby better get the
last name card thinking Simone you know
I will say there are worse people to
make a baby with though Chloe so good on
you you know and you know speaking of
babies there was another celebrity baby
that we welcome yesterday Jamie Lynn
Spears had a daughter joining 9 year old
Maddie this is gonna be her first
daughter with her husband though Jamie
also names Jamie and the daughter's name
is ivy John so congratulations to Jamie
Lynn as well I'm so excited like between
cardi B
we've now jamie-lynn Sophie's pregnant I
mean this is a maternity showed speaking
of babies though it was the birth of her
twin babies that prevented Beyonce from
performing at Coachella last year and
the time has finally come
she's here to make good on her word she
will be performing the next two weekends
at the Coachella Music Festival I will
be there Desiree will be there
Sophie covers music we got a preview for
you guys like no no she will not be
there no she will not be there doesn't
you pregnant